okay guys okay guys this is de mer 1998
now I was lucky to get a press steam key
given to me and I said oh yeah you can't
go for it you know I got for it so let's
just do this it's a third-person shooter
on Steam and it should become an antique
like summer this summer
whoa de Mer mode beginning mode standard
difficulty let's do this
I get brightness brightness just the
brightness until it's just fit so the
image is barely visible yeah do that one
I like it make it a little brighter just
for you guys to see it subtitles yes hot
dammit yes I know vibration a personal
opinion well blah sign I forgot to sign
this okay
let's do this several hours have gone by
since green occasions with a slide
laboratories been cut off now two teams
of highly trained hates hexaco advance
decision division for extraction and
search operatives are called out to
investigate their mission find the
missing researchers has seemingly
vanished without a trace and retrieve
sensitive highly classified materials
for a clandestine branch of the u.s.
government
tasked with gaining access to lower
levels of lab special agent they have
barges into the second service entrance
and it is there that he discovers a
security system has initiated a facility
wide quarantine automatically shutting
it one hand and surveys a warning to
would-be invaders that some kind of
experiment had gone horribly horribly
wrong let's do this
presently dr. George request to
migration of all random personnel couple
overpaid this is a couple of hours a
pleasure spawned anyone can place my
name is Rebecca Jordan I'm a doctor at
the Angus medical facility unearthing
Islands we have a problem of some
magnitude yeah there's situation
building that were quiet oh my god oh my
god they would explode some gas not some
lungs warping people from the inside all
they [ __ ] oh really good animation only
God don't hear God's sake yeah [ __ ] yeah
Hades let's do those pictures that say
again we're a cup low how freaked out
tacked me I thought I rather die than
whatever this contagion is then kill
someone but you got there we got a doubt
right now I don't know how long this
channels to open what that you that you
security bridge triggered some could
have locked down full quarantine chapter
one signal loss let's do this [ __ ]
that transmission was last communication
I have a nice lip towards 12 hours ago
North four Islands Washington State 99
yet de mer you know my god it's a new
crisp agent question is actually the
same experimental gas you've been
ordered to portray okay
no my problem is I forgot to mention
initial brief there's also a new type of
chemical woman that kills everyone hit
on flex oh [ __ ] rest assured all
entourages they killed it automatically
sealed at the first sign of bridge which
a standard security protocol and mishaps
a car huh thank God
gotta love OSHA huh now that your teams
will have filtrate the facility is such
Epsilon you got interview that Center
lobby second level ed your way and I got
serious
his face is really good complexion Jesus
the laboratory Delta something asleep
with lower levels with a main laboratory
okay what am i Delta Epsilon
all right now we're gonna Intel the base
was were the so called gassy carts I'll
proceed cautiously if you say so
please be advised I first have to raise
a party red her people for already Brad
ok so that means like we can't stop for
coffee or anything I could then be
packed coffee beforehand though I know
that medians this will be a simple
section gravity were initially led to
Bailey if good luck gentlemen now get
this shows what made oh the hell that is
Cheerilee that hell is truly the house
of Hades aids Q out party or do you
understand this
Sam it could be our last uh I got a pen
[ __ ] lined up oh we know if you're a
betting man it Bentley hasn't making it
home one piece or a lot better than with
you on the battlefield
ya know that's very true very true but
that's after you know Gomer powers and
put us down first okay shut the [ __ ] up
lab god damn my mouth well that that
[ __ ] then I'll let him get there get
that chip out Scott Denny with a bigger
stick which is pretty much everyone you
know what I'm saying it never should
have pulled his ass out of that fire and
groom 94 they took me
thanks Hayden i major forget it
look let's do this [ __ ] let's do this
[ __ ] we're going in base we're gonna
then okay we're going [ __ ] and that
might be my fan too [ __ ] loud sorry
guys she booted visual range okay I just
turned my [ __ ] fan so maybe we want
to hear this the same an actual descent
let's do this [ __ ] let's [ __ ] it
there let's see immaculate headquarters
you're a mission goeth indicator echo
girl from the 394 at this time 427 Zulu
out [ __ ] let's [ __ ] do with
that where am i Shango there's a second
platform and the aniline for ela f crane
will infiltrate the laboratory via the
third platform let's do this [ __ ] I
love their platform after that Raven now
hold position at Dexter a little bit
remain alert fire to pick up your rubber
suckers over per second and is bestest
do this there's me there's me man
handsomest [ __ ] oh man I'm talking
fitted outfit fitted [ __ ] outfit
that's what I'm [ __ ] talking I don't
I got loose fetch it that make you look
[ __ ] fat I'm not for cure for comfort
I'm here for [ __ ] perfection let's do
this
okay whoa [ __ ] swap hey right let me
[ __ ] lower the [ __ ] graphics
definitely get the game chest up
let me give it a fair chance let's not
slim down by my computer
let's do this patch man I got to tell
you from media it's [ __ ] like look at
the liquid latex or whether [ __ ] is
hello sighs hello flashlight
I know pixie I don't need no [ __ ]
closet but I'll do it for you guys
hello sir okay you know I just saw a
triage Chanel well spray again and I
said uh yeah dual cameras hell yeah no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] blind spots that's
what I'm talking about okay sorry I'm
not an engineer hell yeah baby
if I cannot find a way to recover castor
gas jog sprint while jogging
holy [ __ ] that's pretty nice I really
like it there's like two different
speeds you can run out I don't know why
first really nice okay this is the
canister guys we're trying to get this
get the clean yourself up [ __ ]
we should get throw a ragged I'm gonna
say clean yourself up you disgrace your
[ __ ] ass crazy okay
let's see here let's say here
all right smooth controls very nice very
nice I I so much prefer running with
like the left bumper then [ __ ]
clicking in I don't know why just
longevity I guess it's just eager and
long run because I feel like every game
once I find the sprint I'm just like
[ __ ] all that down that's [ __ ]
disgusting
that's not gonna think Dale hello Sam or
BAM sorry watch a pro now let's say you
like is here that's unfortunate
yes I need to search this place for
survivors this bro ain't gonna make it
to LA yeah baby
quick slaw why reload was first like the
magazine from the quick slot interesting
reload its ex just low reload that's
pretty interesting so if you do fast for
lady look you drop what you have right
now slowly look okay alright
correct me manage also combine it
[ __ ]
okay
that's signal anything going on here now
just typical say say TV and everything
here the best with computers
got a cap supposed to shoot that guy
yeah
we have emission controls that's a very
nice what whoa
they just really threw that back story
I'm making [ __ ] sorry
oh I like that like I go out banter
[ __ ] sprinting okay what is that what
is that okay I've been trained I don't
know why with third-person one so dope
even though it's weird that you like
lose no like no that's about 10% of your
vision cuz of it it's like really
visually feeling we show how that's hair
well disgusting
restore the power first alright no
problem I could do that but I just want
to say in case I fail I'm not an
engineer so no pressure
alright yeah honor aware of the Allied
forces will never understand a 1945 was
[ __ ] what's it doing here is this 98
Tran should go on bloody poor desire
chosen ok weapon 2 and human at a part
of Tokyo expect long journey to the
American coast where the plague will be
unleashed in a story of the science
fiction will run its course so
Wow okay so it's actually like the
Japanese doing this that's crazy
I mean it's actually a really
good-looking game is that how system B
okay
Oh over this wow this game actually a
lot going on oh [ __ ]
energy bar [ __ ] yeah
okay
let's do this [ __ ] I'm a pistol man I'm
gonna pistol-whip this [ __ ] hey
da let's do this [ __ ] whoa whoa whoa
chick status
I don't way to come around okay what's
going on over here
settle down settle down
I hear I hear [ __ ]
I hear [ __ ] like I said I don't know
engineer but looks like a bank
transaction wait at the J fell for a
million dollars
whoa okay
ii do this [ __ ] here default Kevin and
resume is quite impressive
despite rage you were in somewhat a new
sheriff surface to get equipment that
most texts don't even exist how are you
I heard you asked a co-worker what our
research mean depth in here what's about
the UFO yeah so it's basic leg okay here
we go
bassy power outage all India's find a PC
to check which air is shorted out
fortunately there pairs on IMAX gets
restored manually at the control panel I
will turn green
she follows checks on the screen with
any problems don't forget loose lips
sink ships
okay very nice [ __ ] is that already pull
it
okay let me check this out okay so am I
um can't use the green light to portray
people we just got earlier I think it
then what are you been waiting the whole
days with cautions my life yeah okay
email that's opportunity been waiting
for his arrived he hopes cippec's okay
okay your GA okay so that's sick here
well that way they talk about green
light to do whatever retrieve waiting
two days but we got it forget a lot of
precautions our Jenner was coming here
and Christian security can't afford to
delay we're just going to life here
green light green that okay so we got
the map power status now our way
our inch edge top secret top secret okay
except we need it what do we need open
Oh F
let's of' offices area
okay we finally [ __ ] got it it was
essentially just to match the map oh
[ __ ] someone [ __ ] come already the
[ __ ] is that noise holy [ __ ]
yes stupid [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
well I did really bad at that did not do
well but they're not there well
wait no I don't need it anymore let's go
let's [ __ ] go
oh yeah we're a little bit yeah pitch
got up a little [ __ ] alright let's see
here we got some air baby
I might have to cap someone cuz i'll cap
someone i'll give a [ __ ] you a cap son
I'll [ __ ] do it
yes stupid [ __ ] they're dead now [ __ ]
and dad now all right I still that's
what this reloading is for chumps [ __ ]
this guy's skinny is [ __ ] that he's down
target neutralized
great
this bro is not done well okay
oh [ __ ] now I got to go that radio
[ __ ] a lot of aliens here did well
not alien just ugly zombies are you
gonna get up you're gonna get up [ __ ]
powerful cargo area
well okay
we got him head back to the cargo bay
oh [ __ ] where's the damn person a like a
[ __ ] impersonating like a
[ __ ]
I feel I just feel better
you got one bullet left okay
I don't think anything was my right no
okay well what the [ __ ] yeah bad Pepe oh
yeah what's strict Boston yeah yeah a
pinch is still good Sam you know you
can't really complain about these sort
of things you know top [ __ ]
see getting up
yes stupid [ __ ]
I'm getting up a lot lately it's all I
gotta say
they get him airway coward what the [ __ ]
okay hey these guys are [ __ ] tough
did they can really take it wait what's
my Joseph
I think it's activate the elevator and
the cargo area I hear something
this is the elevator to get back up [ __ ]
fucking-a
guys hustling guys are really [ __ ]
hustling you guys know head over there
okay we're gonna do this smartly [ __ ]
there's no am assess because I'm doing
the [ __ ] man mode is he going down
right now
holy [ __ ]
ouch it would not be anyone in here
there's our [ __ ] weapons
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I am sexually [ __ ]
okay yeah
[ __ ]
stupid fish I'm trying to tap this [ __ ]
that a zombie but I died what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] okay
I gotta be like really good at this
[ __ ] I got him okay so that's what I got
to do it just cut a when they go on the
ground just gotta [ __ ] get him again
quick get that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah okay yeah
that's a lot easier it's a lot [ __ ]
easier
we just gotta keep moving [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] a hard hat on
okay I don't have a lot of shots oh [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah daddy likey daddy
likey treated cast her first what the
[ __ ]
okay so how much [ __ ] I got seven I
might take that another guy at seven
this [ __ ] right
all right he's not gonna back up is he
twitching like a [ __ ]
he's going I can't do this [ __ ] let's
do this find our way into the laboratory
easy anything Wow